Jeff Bezos right now owns 10 of Amazon
Elon owns 17 of Tesla these huge guys
understood a concept which is the more
money you can make other people the more
money you make even though the pie is
not 100 yours and it took me too long to
understand because if you give other
people slices of the pie then you can
gain your time back disproportionately
it'd be better to have 51 of 100
businesses than 100 of you know what I
mean because you can just give the
opportunity away but the problem is that
everyone thinks the boat they're in is
the only boat they'll ever be in for the
rest of their lives not to say you
shouldn't focus on that boat but I'm
saying like we think so small